über einen satz gestolpert von von
dorothee bär der bisherigen
digitalisierungs staatsministerin und
die hat gesagt ich habe lust auf zukunft
und das ist eigentlich also ein satz wie
man sie nicht mehr hören kann der
wahlkampf ist die hohe zeit der phrasen
und der sinnentleerten setze ich habe
lust auf zukunft ja kommt sie denn nicht
wenn man keine lust drauf hat geht
morgen die sonne nicht mehr auftrat
wären selbst experten die sogar jan
böhmermann für zulässig hält der ansicht
doch sie geht morgen wieder auf das kann
also nicht gemeinsam was ist gemeint wir
sind ganz vorne dran wir sind bei der
hochtechnologie ja das ist prima kann
ich mir aber nichts darunter vorstellen
wenn ich für zukunft bin und nun muss
man mal sagen die gute
dorothee bär ist nicht ganz allein
schuld sie hat einen großteil der
kompetenzen aus der hand genommen
bekommen das kanzleramt hat sich dessen
angenommen helge braun er war
christiansen digitalisierungs minister
scheuer waren noch mit im boot am ende
ist nicht viel herausgekommen also man
hat den eindruck wenn hier leute über
die zukunft reden das ist leute von
gestern sind die einem was von morgen
erzählen und das heute nicht in griff
sehr richtig und da wird einem dann doch
ein bisschen der kam ich möchte ohne
hingegen will lachmuskeln ich möchte uns
davor warnen jetzt im wahlkampf hat die
hohe zeit setzte von setzen die anfangen
mit wir brauchen wir müssen wir wollen
für all diese sätze liebe zuschauer
können sie sich nichts kaufen das ist
eine bemühen zusage eine erkenntnis
frage derjenigen die dort auf dem podium
stehen hinterher haben sie nicht gesagt
ich verspreche ihnen oder bei mir wird
ist so und so kommen sondern ist einfach
nur ich habe auch euer problem erkannt
aber ob ich löse das muss man abwarten
also ich bewundere herren schule wie er
sich da unbeirrt durch diesen ozean der
plattitüden der deutschen politik kämpft
und ich kann das natürlich 100%
nachempfinden denn bei uns zu hause ist
das genau gleich freuen wenn sie schauen
begriffe wie digitalisierung kommen das
ist ja ganz schlimm also wenn ein
politiker gar nichts mehr einfällt wenn
er gar kein problem lösen glauben dann
redet er von digitalisierung dann hast
du einen gewissen applaus auf sich doch
das ist ein fortschritt gehört das ist
eine ganz schlaue politikerin aber ich
kann einfach sorgen für alle die das
noch dran glauben ich habe nochmals
unserem ich kann aus meinem aus der
schweiz mit teilen alle
digitalisierungsprojekte liebe statt
angeleitet als lea durchgezogen als kann
massivste kostenüberschreitung
korruption also wirklich mit schmiergeld
totale ineffizienz und am schluss im
unterschied zur privatwirtschaft wo die
digitalisierung immer zum stellenabbau
führt führt sie beim start zum
stellenaufbau deshalb ist es falsch zu
behaupten die digitalisierung kostet
jobs windows dem start gibst dann gibt's
legionen von jobs aber beim start ist
auch so wenn die noch für die computer
zuständig werden dann werden computer
noch so groß wie tun hat die auf diese
angebliche reinhören ich habe in berlin
seit einem halben jahr versucht einen
termin bei einer behörde zu kriegen um
einen pass zu verlängern und das ist mir
nach einem halben jahr durch zufall
gelungen weil da muss man nämlich
ständig lauern schon am frühen morgen
leicht unter den grünen wir dass man
ihren posten nicht an mir früher immer
andere können aber heute nicht so jetzt
habe ich durch zufall eingeklickt der
frei geworden ist aber das war kein
zustand hier laufen in berlin laufen
nach meiner information ungefähr 50.000
leute rum die keine gültigen papiere
haben weil sie keinen termin kriegen
warum kann man so einen pass oder
ausweis nicht digital bloß aufgeregt
oder und dann kriegt man ihnen
zugeschickt
haben ausnahmsweise recht geben aber man
wäre trotzdem dabei probieren sie doch
ob er dafür auch die schuld weil ich
finde es eigentlich nicht angemessen
eine einzige person affäre einer
deutlich zu machen dass wir das nicht
hinbekommen der digitalisierung es ist
weil wir um eine dunkle werd ich kenne
sie auch ein bisschen näher die mit sehr
viel enthusiasmus ideen und auch mehr
repräsentationen von zukunft immer
wieder aufgehalten worden ist und der
immer wieder die tür vor der nase
zugeschlagen wurde und wenn diese
kompetenzen eben abgezogen werden und
eine königin ohne königreich kann halt
nicht so gut regieren und da glaube ich
schon ist es unfair dass jetzt zu
personalisieren auf dorothea sondern
dann müssen wir die grundsatzfrage
stellen was in den letzten jahrzehnten
los war aber würden sich zusätzlich zur
schaufensterpuppe machen zu lassen ist
natürlich auch
lernen sie hat dieses etikett
digitalisierung angeklebt bekommen und
sie hat die macht nicht bekommen ist
umzusetzen und das darf man sich nicht
gefallen lassen in der politik wenn man
dafür ja mit rumläuft und immer nur die
gamescom eröffnet dann ist man ein stück
weit auch selbst schuld dass man pflege
einer schwierigen propheten ich weiß ich
weiß dass sie sehr viel kann sehr viel
weiß dass sie sich ums gaming kümmert
alles klar neben
der robotik ist auch eines ihrer
steckenpferde ich sagen
muss griffe und beliebt ist
sie werden jetzt haben sie ist nicht nur
die eigene partei hinaus will ist sieht
das also gerade über die frau sie ist
über die eigene partei hinaus gar nicht
bekannt das stimmt nicht nur weil er
europäer so werde obama auch in der
bunten im dünne ich glaube die halbe
bevölkerung kennt sie spesen seitdem mut
und die halbe bevölkerung liest muss ich
mich da mal begraben ich muss ich eine
beruhigende these einstreuen wenn das
größte problem deutschland store ob er
wäre dann würde das land zählt wollte
ich wollte
es geht um den kanzlerkandidaten der
dorop er aufbietet als aushängeschild
für digitalisierung dafür ist sie nicht
geeignet weil dem staat nichts gelungen
ist auf der werre denn dafür geeignet
herr schuler
da gibt es sicherlich ein paar leute die
sehr viel davon verstehen aber nicht
präsentabel werden also der ist voll
selbst vermarkten hat sich sehr gut
hingekriegt nur sie hätten versuchen
müssen immer darauf hinzuweisen dass sie
der treibende keil ist der die druck
form die das voranbringen will aber
nicht gelassen wird und so hat sie
leider das marketing image über geholfen
bekommen ohne wirklich das liefern zu
können und am ende gehen dann auch die
misserfolge hier zu hause das ist die
typische ungerechtigkeit wie sie in der
politik herrscht und hat nichts mit
frauenfeindlichkeit oder mit europäer
persönlich zu tun das ist einfach das
problem was du hast andreas scheuer als
verkehrsminister ist image mäßig auch
ganz unten angesiedelt was auch damit zu
tun haben dass ein experte für autobahn
was braucht man will zu tun hat ist dass
dem bdv zahl der journalisten sich über
das andere geschäft was nicht heißt mit
verkehrspolitik gar nicht beschäftigt
also gleich entwicklungspläne wasser
straßenausbau alles sachen die er macht
und die auch gut laufen die nimmt aber
keiner zur kenntnis insofern ist das die
ganz normale ungerechtigkeit die
europäer trifft die im politischen
geschehen drin ist und da muss man sich
entweder erwehren oder man hat eine sehr
aktive gerechtigkeit dass die leute die
in ihren ämtern versagt haben irgendwann
auch nicht mehr ankommen aber wer ist
denn gut also man merkt ja auch in der
bevölkerung so eine
politikverdrossenheit und die hat
bestimmt auch wieder mit zu tun wenn man
natürlich immer auch die meinungen über
politiker hat diesen wir wollen nicht
alle meinungen hören ich glaube wir sind
hier so ein blog in der sache du hast
dich alleine du brauchst also mehr
redezeit der kreis hat doro werden gut
gemacht und dann gibt es politiker so
sagen wie schön es ist lange hoffnungs
prozesse haben ja sehr viel auch mit
arroganz zu tun haben wir gerade
politiker beschrieben der von oben herab
auf leute guckt und ich glaube das macht
leute für wütender als wir uns
vorstellen könnt möchte und dorothea ist
jemand also der nada ist also so habe
ich sie kennengelernt der zugänglich ist
der menschlich ist wo man zum telefon
greifen kann und ein projekt hat ich
habe mehrere
menschenrechtsorganisationen werden die
bildungsinitiative und wir sagen wir
haben was geplant digital aber auch mit
der sozialen komponente das ist eine der
ersten gesagt wir kriegen das hin das
ist jemand die auch leute ins
bundeskanzleramt holt die vielleicht
nicht sofort da vorgesehen sind wir
eingeladen sind da kam ich auch in
unterschiedlichen unterschiedliche
veranstaltungen erinnern insbesondere
auch was die konsumenten und so weiter
darum geht es ja nicht jetzt natürlich
wieder ins lächerliche aber hat mich
aber
ich finde einfach dass greifen zu kurz
darum geht es mir gut ich bin jetzt
nicht die pressesprecherin von druck
werde ich dass ich da falsch verstanden
werde aber ich find's einfach wichtig
auch von persönlichen erfahrungswerten
einfach zu sprechen und ich habe sie da
einfach anders erlebt und das ist etwas
was ich tatsächlich an ihre schätze und
was mich manchmal wundert bei dem ein
oder anderen politiker wo ich mir die
frage stelle mit welchem recht nimmst du
dir diese arroganz weil das jeder hat
also wo sich was stört muss ich jetzt
einräumt das ist eine der
erfolgreichsten figuren die dazu in
diesen zukunftsthemen weil solange es
über das zukunftsteam noch nie
diskutiert worden wie eben über dorothea
ja dann entstanden also eine große große
frau die system aber es scheint eine der
wichtigsten das will ich in russland sie
ganz deutschland zu sein ja im kern
glaube ich auch dass die nächste
regierung die ja schon wohlweislich von
einem modernisierungs jahrzehnt spricht
also in der nächsten legislatur nimmt
die sie erst gar nicht vor das zu
schaffen sondern sie geht erst mal auf
zehn jahre dass auch die nächste
kanzlerschaft das nicht wird lösen
können das problem bei der
digitalisierung liegt in deutschland
viel tiefer gerade bei der öffentlichen
verwaltung denn wenn man eine verwaltung
modernisieren und digitalisieren will
dann muss man die gesamte belegschaft
schulen da muss man einen plan machen
dafür was passiert wenn der handwerker
den durchbruch in der einen wand macht
und das kabel gelegt dann muss ja dieser
arbeitsplatz an einen anderen raum
verlegt das geht nicht einfach ohne den
verwaltungsrat angehört zu haben es ist
hochgradig kompliziert solche prozesse
überhaupt in gang zu bringen und bevor
dann ein einziges dokument wie zb der
reisepass online zu beantragen ist denn
die daten hat der staat ja bereits er
hat ja einen pass ausgestellt als man
müsste eigentlich war nur auf
verlängerung drücken ist er das ja auch
keiner neuen reisepass zugeschickt
bekommen bild bevor das passiert gehen
werden weiterhin jahre ins land gehen
das ist kein pessimismus sondern
realismus
[Musik]